[Musique]
j'étais sur un incendie dans le montana
et en un claquement de doigts le feu
s'est transformé en brasier
surgissant des flammes un ours est
apparu c'est la chose la plus
merveilleuse c'est la plus terrifiante
que j'ai pu voir
tôt ou tard le feu va s'inviter dans la
ville qui les a vus naître ça fait
quatre ans qu'on s'entraîne on a fait
tout honneur on a nos diplômes mais tant
qu'elle sera pas certifiée pompiers
d'élite mon unité jouera les seconds
couteaux sur le terrain
tu veux en parler ou tu continues à
faire tourner jonway
c'est pas facile de partager son âme
avec le feu prend à cette campagne
au revoir les amours imprégnez vous de
cette magnifique vue parce qu'une fois
que vous aurez été baptisé vous ne
regarderez plus jamais cette beauté
sauvage comme avant
ce qui se passe là haut le feu menace la
population et les habitations
je veux les granits montagny si vous
l'avez fait vous êtes pompiers d'élite
il vous faut une équipe de choc pour
cette mission
s'il faut nous dépasse il fonce sur la
ville vous aurez une impression de fin
du monde
tant que vous pourrez respirer ou
survivre et
nous allons attaquer le peu de pâte et
trouver notre ville
line of fire personne ne peut être plus
fier de ses hommes que je le suis
aujourd'hui le 13 septembre en icinéma
sur vos services de vidéo à la demande
exclusivement chez vous